I'm a little quick to cover up because we're
here from school.
I don't know the beginning, it was 6. I don't know
how long it will be and you
'll leave a child here. I didn't think it was ours.
you're still alive
at least Well, nothing is waiting for the neighbor
, some girls called here, then the
boys called, they came running. Well, for
now, all the lucky ones arrived, they
cast him. Well, they put it
out with the rib.
At first, you were sleeping, the explosion
started, the windows were scattered, and I came out here to
look  and heard a neighbor calling for
help, saying that his mother had passed out, they
started calling everyone they
could.
Then they started to
pull her out themselves. I talked to her. She said
that she couldn't breathe, that something was lying on top of her,
then the boys came running and helped to
save the woman, but she was saved by
what  her table turned over
and he bought
did
and she had air